This episode of Your Mom's house is brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Well,
no,
go to your mom's house.
Christina.
Jean,
go ahead.
Oh,
and tell people what,
oh Jeez.
I'm not even,
oh dear.
Oh dear.
What a morning.
We've had folks,
let me tell you,
we've been all over the place trying to get our lives.
Uh,
so yeah,
I've got it's,
it's been,
it's been quite,
it's been
barely holding shit together,
but that's what's exciting.
I have two major announcements.
The first being I'm taping a half hour for Netflix,
June 4th,
uh,
in Las Vegas.
It's called the degenerates of comedy and Joey Coco Diaz is arm.
The lineup is huge.
A big Jay Oakerson and,
and a few others.
I'm sorry,
whose name I don't recall at the moment,
but you can come to this live taping for free by going to my website.
Pacino p online.
Do you use the Promo Code?
Can you turn it down just a little?
The most
use promo code your mom.
That's why o u r m o m for preferential seating.
That's the thing guys,
they don't know you're a fan of your mom's house unless you use that code,
your mom and then they will make,
I was told,
I was promised they will give you seating at the front of the venue so you can
be up close and you can see Joey and myself telling horrific jokes for the
degenerates of comedy for Netflix.
And in the meantime,
La Peeps,
I'm going to be running my set for Netflix,
May 31st in the belly room at the comedy store,
8:00 PM show.
Uh,
we got Sam Tripoli on that lineup.
We got Ryan Sickler,
Steve Simone and,
and,
and a few others.
Limited tickets are available on that one.
Also at Christina p online.
Uh,
November 24th,
San Diego House of Blues and then December 8th Jew Dork titties at the Grammercy
theater.
So very exciting stuff.
And then also a July 17th,
Cardi B and I will be delivering our babies
on the same side day.
So awesome that you guys work that out.
Yeah,
she's been hearing about it on Twitter.
And you know,
so far we haven't heard from her,
but I'm sure she'll get back to us.
This is a thank you for the instrumental.
Uh,
the wets od Vaughn down.
Barry stay awhile.
Yes,
I am in a
Charlotte.
All those shows are sold out.
Then I go to
Omaha.
Same Zs,
some tickets left for brass balls,
beach,
Florida,
the West Palm Beach Improv a 25th is nearly sold out.
24.
It has some tickets.
Uh,
25 tickets remain for New Orleans.
Where the third show?
Boise,
we added a second show ball,
Sacramento,
Fresno,
Bakersfield,
Jack me off.
Phil Orlando and a second show in Philadelphia.
All on sale.
[inaudible] dot com slash tour.
That's what's up.
It's a lot going on in this house,
Huh?
I know.
It really is a lot.
Goodness.
We got a new life coming pretty soon.
It is true.
We're shooting things.
We're doing stuff.
There's a lot a guys check it out.
All right,
let's get this show on the road.
Here we go.
Everybody.
So this would probably be my most popular service out of all the services I do.
Am I most erotic service?
What's the squad?
Him Shave.
Don't bring in one month.
Well,
we'll go to your mom's house.
Happy Birthday.
Big Boy.
Who's on your shirt today?
Yeah.
Rest in peace.
Be Aig.
Be 46 today.
I ain't crazy.
Wow.
Think about how much that guy did and how much he ate.
Terrible.
He's here.
He's really fat.
He was,
he was amazing.
Amazing lyricist.
Ah,
the Great Sam triple snaps.
46 big.
Can you imagine that?
Can't believe that.
I mean,
he was so good and all that was put out by like 23 yeah,
because I feel like he died in 96 I want to say.
Yeah,
it was like early,
so he was fucking 24 25
it's crazy.
I wouldn't even understand that power.
I would flame throat everything.
I would only be able to play Reno because I burned every bridge and like socks.
Man.
That was stupid.
I know,
but that's a stupid,
you're a whole new appreciation for fame and success at a really early on.
Like when I see,
I couldn't understand it to 1819 year olds.
Everybody be pregnant.
You're like,
oh my God.
No.
But that would have run through all the money.
All of it.
At 23 you've earned $30 billion.
I'd be like,
after that 45 yeah,
I'd be red.
Foxing it at like 24 IRS becoming in,
grabbing white tigers out of my house.
Yeah.
Did he,
did he spend like that?
Oh,
oh yeah.
Yeah.
I don't know if he got tigers,
but just buying crazy shit.
He,
oh that's so good.
Boy.
He got his success later in life.
I have a theory that black comedians go nuts.
Okay,
let's save this data later on.
Later on.
Okay,
cool.
Here's yet another example.
I go down rabbit holiday for later.
Yeah.
Black can meet.
Sorry,
what was it?
Black comedians go crazy.
Go croquet.
Okay.
This is yet another example of guys acting like they're running a legit
business.
Sexual going,
nothing sexual.
Totally.
To get your dick hard.
Yeah.
Oh,
so this is a,
it's all about jizzing on some naked barber
hitting in the running service cause he used the same
clippers on both parts like her head.
And your asshole.
I sure hope so.
I'd be like,
Hey,
can you use whatever you use to to shave that guy's balls on my face right now
for my beard?
Yeah.
Did you want my naked for this?
Obviously I'm the naked and he's just walking around with those.
He's always ready to go get a lot of guys that
not that well hung.
They don't want to feel intimidated.
What I would call an average flight.
You get your ass home
bleach if you have nipple rings.
Am I right?
Oh,
for sure.
Oh wait,
I missed what he said.
Did he say that he considers himself average?
Is that what he said is like in great shape,
but what?
What does he say?
How long?
They don't want to feel intimidated being in what I would call it.
Average flow is probably a lot better than if I was some funky model.
Oh yeah.
Steroids,
body and big Dick.
So,
oh,
he's saying that he's average,
which is,
you know,
like makes people feel at ease
when you're doing ass in general.
To waxing,
you have to add a beautician or anything.
You have to get in these different areas.
Look at this shit.
This is not what women do that I've always imagined what you girls do.
I just got waxed and I go,
how do you do the ball hole?
Shit.
There's this,
they put you in a swing and then just get in there.
Yeah.
Here's
the thing.
Heterosexual women who have the exact service done,
they don't put you in a fuck swing and a leather daddy with a hat and a harness.
Does it do wearing a jockstrap?
I'm just always amazed how the gay guys look so alike.
It's like you're just going fuck by yourself.
Right?
It's so weird.
Yeah.
They look alike and they are.
The truth is this dude called himself in average shape.
He's an average shape,
uh,
for,
for his world.
For a gay guy.
Yeah.
He's sloppy,
right?
Yeah.
For us,
it's like fucking workout.
Tom Wright always coming up.
This would be like a shredded body.
I'd be like,
Hey,
$1 million to have this too.
He'd be one of those dudes just always hanging out with his shirt off and you're
like fuck and a yeah,
and you can ask it something and it actually makes me feel like shit that he
called himself average Logan.
I mean God,
my gay friend,
uh,
and Portland we,
he talks about all the time,
he's like,
you have such low standards.
Women,
straight women for heterosexual man.
He's like,
it would never fly in our community when you guys is acceptable
and they're children of the corn dude.
Once you like age out,
you're like abandoned.
No,
not anymore.
It's different up there cause he's,
he's aging and now there's a whole,
there's a community for that for like something old,
overweight,
what would beard it.
But if you showed up for everybody,
show up in your 20s or 30s and you're like,
dude,
you're not working out.
They're going to get,
you're going to get crumbs if that's what you meant.
I wish you two are gay guys.
So yeah,
no.
Well,
I just got a tattoo on my leg of my area code where I'm at because I'm Mexican
trash dude.
Right.
That's what Latinos do.
They love that.
Put their area code.
So I put it on,
which is six oh seven and of course red band comes up who like is the mayor of
like four Chan and reddit.
And he informed me that six oh seven basically means it's a gay term to shoot.
Come in your asshole.
But I'm cool with that too.
You know,
it's like it's my hometown or you like to get weird.
Either way I'm in,
you know really what that means.
That's what he said to me and somebody sent it to me.
I bet red bands,
right?
Look it up on like a,
I like urban dictionary.
It's like,
it's like fist pumping cheers or something like that.
Does know all these things though.
But he's,
when he's drunk,
he comes with that devil smirk and you just know he's about to talk some mad
shit.
Yeah,
of course.
Um,
so funny.
That's so hilarious.
Yeah.
Again,
this is not sexual.
These are just a bunch of guys.
Just who need a shave on their scrotum and there just happens to be a fuck swing
and guys in harnesses,
and this is a very innocent,
I find that the female equivalent of this is Instagram models who do like humble
brags.
Like they tried to do funny pictures with their bolt holes flapping.
They're like,
oh,
just chilling like a villain and you're like,
you could see into their soul through their asshole and it's just such a weird
humblebrag Instagram girl who shows her tears her ass.
And then she's like,
and when people comment and like Nice tits rash,
she's like,
stop objectifying me.
I'm just trying to take a nice picture for me though.
When they call their fans their fam,
it's like,
oh by the way,
your fam is beating off to you just to let you know Uncle Sam's going knuckles
up on it.
Right.
This is saying that it also needs to give a blowjob,
like would you want to suck?
So seven after school.
It's so weird,
right?
It's just my home town.
I have to change it to 1607 lifeguard code for a Turd in the pool.
It's magical.
All round,
written upside down.
It spells log.
So,
uh,
at this very moment,
Richard is shaving my balls at the end of my Gig,
it's going to make my dick look a bit bigger,
which is always a nice thing.
It's an amazing feeling.
It's just like,
dude,
it's not something that I wouldn't normally,
let's do
it.
Smell experience.
And he's quite arousing.
Yeah,
of course.
It's a little bit arousing.
Here's,
I mean,
hold on,
hold on.
This is that what's coming up here?
Oh,
I see.
Like a lot of guys shaved their own bowls.
I don't get the shape right.
They usually go to high,
stuff like that.
Like most things I always fun sloughing off stuff.
Someone else do it for you.
That kind of his dick is like,
it's touching.
Tapping your ass on that.
He's shaving
like you really don't need to be naked doing this service,
but you've just decided to jump
barriers 100% no reason to do this.
But for the Guy Shaving horse,
slept staff saying,
I'll stuff for you.
Then the duty.
So a lot of women go in and get weekly blow drives.
I get a few clients that come in for a weekly sprout and shape.
Okay.
Here's the part that we knew was coming up because this is always in everything
like this.
Usually you find enough straight guys.
I've shaved straight guys balls before.
Sure,
sure,
sure.
Find that strike guys up that are really comfortable.
They know who that
man.
Everybody's got a work uniform.
Yeah.
Do you think the stripe guys know that they're secretly gay guys?
Because here's,
here's a,
I'll tell you a little secret.
Those weren't straight guys.
No.
Okay.
There's no such thing as this.
I think the kids growing up right now are all going to be bisexual.
They watch so much porn.
Yeah.
The amount of Dick save seen compared to their grandpa.
Like a couple in the army and the fucking showers.
Yeah.
Dick's for debt,
like mountains of Dick's.
These get,
these young kids have seen it.
They're definitely totally comfortable with it probably.
Yeah,
and it's like,
fuck it.
Hey holes.
Be Weird.
Get a six or seven.
Yay.
Hey,
what?
Speaking of hair cuts,
um,
why don't you tell them about your haircut experience and how I helped you,
mother,
let's talk about almost divorced to me last week.
So,
uh,
oh yeah.
By the way,
so a straight guys,
if you
want to go see the naked Barbara,
I don't know if it's info on where he is,
but um,
either New Zealand it sounds like.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You should sponsor the podcast.
You know the Nike Baba,
his name is Dick Savvy.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Given name.
Oh,
says Christian is,
he enjoys,
I enjoy watching other guys get off on it.
That's where I know I've got a good business.
But as far as the pain,
my fetish,
no,
you won't want to pay certain luffing off on shaving aleks and yeah.
Cause you thinking he's getting off just as much as I'm getting off.
Why am I paying for this?
Yeah,
it's,
they're not like where does he live?
Is there enough business to keep them open?
Like is like,
is he living with his mom and he's like,
this is my art.
Like I mean in Hollywood there's so many gates.
It's like the,
it's the business of gay.
This is Mecca for Bud fucking SCO.
But Sandy Yarrow isn't even close to this.
How are you?
That's me.
Can I see the back?
Is it still wracked?
No,
it's fixed.
So I shaved my own head.
And by the way,
a bunch of people were like,
I didn't think you were cheap.
Why are you,
I was like,
I didn't do it to be,
it's not to save money.
It was to save time.
Yeah.
I was always going to go to the gay barber,
but that was always going to get this easy.
You want to fly to New Zealand haircut.
So,
you know,
I used to get it like a little more shaped,
but as I lost hair in the front,
I'm like,
I'll just throw clippers on and have this be done.
You know?
So when I was shooting that,
that movie,
the,
uh,
the hair guy,
I told him,
I was like,
I really want to do this.
I have some clippers.
What clippers should I get?
He,
he's like,
these are the best lippers order these.
And then he goes,
do you know you'll learn how to do it?
You kind of feel your head and,
and so I ordered them,
I start,
I get the,
the guards and I,
I do my first path,
right?
So I do it and then I go into the,
see Christina in the bedroom when I go,
how did I do in the back?
And she's like,
Oh,
you missed like a strip up here.
And I reached and I'm like,
Oh yeah,
I did.
First of all,
you go back in there,
hold on.
Okay,
go back in there,
clean that up,
try to then do my neck and then go back in.
And I'm like,
how's it look if she's like,
looks great.
Then this,
the day that I do that,
I go do two shows at the comedy store.
I go out to dinner the next night.
Then the following day I walk into the gym and as I put my stuff in,
like this cubby that my trainers standing,
I hear him go,
what your trainer?
Yeah.
He goes,
the fuck happened to your head,
Huh?
And I go,
what?
And he goes,
dude.
And he takes a pill.
He takes this picture.
He's like,
your neck is jacked,
bro.
And then I sent her this picture.
Go,
what the fuck you told me it looked good.
I liked it.
Thank you.
Unfuckable that's what she doesn't want anybody to look at that.
Beanna may I present my side of the case please?
First of all,
you came into the room.
I was laying on the bed.
It was nighttime.
The,
the room was dimly lit.
And you pointed,
you go,
how does my head look?
And you point at the top of your head.
I never shaved my head.
I don't know that neck lines or I don't fucking know.
I mean,
how about the next few days after this?
I ain't even looking at that stuff.
So I look,
I saw you've got a spot here.
You didn't say,
Hey,
is it,
you look at the Bot.
I don't know.
I'm,
I don't cut men's hair.
I don't shave guys.
Scrotums how do you fucking know?
It looks like a u s jobs chart where it's like up and down,
up,
down,
down.
It's like rock bottom.
Everybody's unemployed.
Yeah,
you're,
the worst part was about this day was that when he's the guy took the picture
when I got to the gym to work out and at the beginning and then the whole time,
you know when someone tells you something like that,
you're like I can't,
I can't focus on this right now.
Yeah.
He,
he knows.
She's like,
you want to go fix your neck right and you're not in the zone.
You have to go.
You're not in the zone dog.
Not In the zone dog.
And I go,
I know I just fucking,
I go,
I can't stop thinking about it.
He was like,
go get your clippers.
I'll fix it for you.
Oh so he's a trainer slash.
Hairstylist as well.
Cause he bleach her asshole too.
He bleaches,
he shaves,
he does account and gay Baba.
He does it all
you it.
But then I fixed it for you to be fair,
you came home and you were so mad at me and I,
I,
I didn't know what I'd done wrong.
And,
and that my neck line is a midway through the
top of the back of my head.
Let's see it.
Oh yeah,
I like that a lot.
It's fine.
Person the bottom,
we'll meet the top and they'll just be like,
I was cursing her name,
weird air horns.
He was so mad at me.
But I'm never,
I'm never done that.
So all I'm saying is I can't see Megan Markle doing that to Prince Harry.
Let's talk about it.
How many times have you guys watched the royal wedding?
Where did you set your alarm?
You did 4:00 AM I just,
you know that I wrote that,
I tweeted that.
Yes.
And since I hashtagged it,
like,
you know,
and,
and that was a popular search term.
I mean hundreds of people were like,
me too.
It's so beautiful.
And I was looking,
it was all British people and the women love this shit.
I loved it.
I watched it and not the whole four hours I watched the highlights.
But what I love best about Meghan Markle is that her family's trash.
Like mine.
Yeah.
Like her dad sold photos to the Paparazzi and then was uninvited,
uninvited.
And then she's got like this derelict nephew who grows weed for a living who
named a strand of weed after her.
She's like,
thanks asshole.
Like I love that she's in the royal family and she's just,
she's got these horrible
glass holes in it.
In her.
I had a family member who is probably one of the top,
uh,
upstate New York meth cookers.
He's doing four to five right now.
The father,
oh no,
four to five.
But he was known as the camera.
So I mean,
we all have weirdness in our family.
This is a close relative.
Oh yeah.
He like tried to rob.
He was my cousin's husband.
He tried to rob a Walmart for sudafed.
Oh yeah.
That's where you get it.
That's what you do when you're a chemist.
I get that.
That sheet rock and yeah,
I was in upstate New York.
It is shady as shit.
It's not,
you know,
everybody's like,
I'm from the hood.
I'm like,
I'm from upstate New York,
dude.
It is ghetto country,
It is shady shit.
That's where the sex Cole is from the big sec sculpted.
They're busing everybody right now.
Albany,
New York rate where I'm from upstate,
anywhere like few hundred miles
from the main city always has the sketchiest shit.
Think about what's a couple of hundred miles north of La.
That's some sketch boss Chris Field is.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Math is math is time travel.
Like you're in the middle of nowhere and you're like,
I don't want to deal for the next week math and now it's fucking a week's gone
by and it just,
and then you drive the Vegas and there's just this weird out of nowhere.
There's like a,
a trailer in the middle of fucking nowhere and you're like,
you are on the run from some state.
There's no reason to be in the middle of the desert right there.
Oh,
by the way,
for stroke gang.
Talk to me.
What is this?
The kids are talking about it.
Yes.
Me pull it up for you.
Um,
I want to get this right.
I said the best.
So
you're going to love this dude.
Um,
let me get this ready for you.
Hold on.
Okay.
Is this the guy?
I think this is the guy.
If you pet any kind of her tile,
it's order product vomited.
Three,
forget that bag or forget about Sally's.
Forget about Dick and plants and all that stuff.
So I don't know if you believe me or not.
Oh God,
you smoked meth with a small limp Dick at Dan.
Get hardly any other way and watch it get harder and harder.
Norris smoke harder.
My Dick get to sound believable.
Yeah.
So this guy,
have you heard of that before Sammy?
He's a time traveler smoking that.
It's trying to waste a week.
Yeah.
Have you ever smoked meth and a major penis as hard as this guys?
Once in a while,
like back when you do coke,
there's someone will give you some coke and you're like,
ah,
this isn't coke,
this is math and boom,
we coast by you.
So it's like it does happen.
But Dad doing the mill knowers probably got nothing fucking going on.
And the boy is that the s four stroking?
Well,
well here.
Okay.
No.
So origins.
Yeah.
Let me get you the four stroke.
Okay.
It's amazing.
People put this on film.
Yeah.
It's so amazing.
Like this might come back and fast.
Fuck it.
He's high.
Well,
something actually happened with him.
Uh,
and the fact that he put it on film because he put it on a film and then we put
it on film and then he was like up.
He took it off.
Oh,
did he hit you back on?
Hey Dude,
no,
no.
He just took,
he removed his own.
The Mommy's kind of found him and had their way with him.
We had that file ripped.
You won't believe how good it feels.
Good.
If you're straight,
he won't believe how good it bills you're declared become so sensitive that you
don't need lube.
You don't need spirit.
You're just decay so much going on here and do this.
And he would shoot an enormous amount of very thick,
thick,
high white come.
Ah,
got it on the brain.
Right.
That's all they think of.
All they care about is coming.
Yeah.
It's just the testosterone,
you guys,
it's all we care about choosing all day.
Pretty nuts.
I mean it is like,
I think it's different for some people and I think if,
I mean it is like a constant thing,
but if you are somebody who,
uh,
also has like,
you know,
what's it called?
Uh,
um,
drug problems or something and then yeah,
it's exacerbated.
Oh yeah.
Did really drug and sex addiction or like tag team champions did.
Yeah,
for sure.
They like to get weird.
How's your show taking a hit since they took down like the,
the casual encounters on craigslist now you can't go get all those sweet looking
for weirdness.
Oh no worry.
We get the video sent to.
Oh,
good,
good.
Well there's plenty of that stuff.
Don't worry about it.
Yeah.
Uh,
so the forest stroke gang is an homage to this clip of this saying that when he
smoked mad that he can come and four strokes,
God and also dusting,
right?
I mean,
would you wear or it's a super power.
It could be one of the other could go either way,
but Sammy,
would you wear a shirt?
It's not just him though,
that that came in forced drugs.
He also introduced this product too.
God Damn it.
Why the fuck is this happening to me,
dude?
Your production value is amazing.
If that's the worst thing that happens.
So it's pretty,
and believe me,
when he smoked with me,
put it this take,
I can't believe how big his dick was.
He checked off and throw out the most common,
every shot is like he's only 49.
And he's fine.
He has no problems.
It gets even harder,
thicker,
and even more coming believes mail
that's math just gives you the fuck.
It's right.
You're like,
oh,
you're my brother.
You're gonna stroke it.
Pocket.
Have you ever does your job with your brother and no math?
No.
So the forced drug gang,
Christ from this and then we grow.
We did do the,
um,
the four stroke gang shirt,
which Christina thought we would sell five of.
She's like,
nobody wants a woman's going to wear for stroke gang.
You've already exed out half the audience.
It's sold out.
I had to reorder it immediately.
You are,
you two are the best at t shirt.
I don't unders.
Wow.
You're amazing.
Here's the thing.
Here's another thing.
I don't,
no.
So one of the things that happened is we did a golf inspired for stroke.
Sure.
Cause you stroke cause you don't want to put like Jackie your divine right.
Right,
right.
What about a calm beer rob?
Rob,
does that make sense?
So we put that out there.
You put the golf one out there.
Um,
it went really well but a lot of people were like this should have been an
engine.
Four stroke engines,
motorcycles for stroke.
So I got went ahead and re ordered also a four stroke engine.
Sure.
For the all the uh,
motorheads there is a four stroke engine on top of that.
I also have a four stroke hat coming.
Oh um,
yeah.
So it's all about getting high and jacking in your car.
And that's what we're all about.
That,
that's the best part.
You go to grandma's house for Thanksgiving,
you got a four stroke because I've been like,
I'm upstate New York,
we'll go to weddings and Jean shorts.
So I'll wear a four stroke at a fucking holy ceremony.
I'll do it.
I love it.
So,
let's see,
how many girls by,
do you think they go knuckles up when they forced drug?
Yeah,
that's a little crazy.
I have a joke about that.
Like,
okay,
sorry about that.
Those topics.
Okay.
Put that on there.
Yeah.
Oh,
when we read back the minutes later.
Oh we should corporate.
We should get to this cause is here.
Yes.
Um,
so tell us these guys.
So everybody knows to try it out.
Obviously try it.
Try it out as one of the clouds plastic to try it out,
eh?
Oh,
try it out.
And not only that,
this Yani Laurel debate that's been going on very similar to our debate of,
Oh,
right.
Yeah.
Or whole man out.
Very similar to this.
What do you hear?
A lot of people were debating,
some people still said,
well,
100%.
It's a,
it's a whole man out.
You know,
I'm home.
I'm home here now.
Home here now is what we thought it was.
Just somebody beat me.
No.
Yeah.
What do you hear?
Do you hear whole man now?
Did you hear Homea know a whole whole me out homie.
Oh,
guess what?
Some people see I tried to create.
So here's the,
here's the in real time express gave me home,
Ya know,
um,
here's an isolator.
Oh this is my dream.
Here's,
here's it with like some breaks in between.
I think he's saying home here now,
but he's so worked up on home here now cause he gave out his address before and
he's like,
Oh yeah,
I'm a home here now.
Yes.
No,
this is like ancient aliens were just solving mysteries
and he's like,
if you're in the building,
if you're in jail,
you're going to building would come and pick somebody pissed on me right now.
Yeah.
Well to the people listening,
it's going to sound like we're just playing that again.
But Sammy,
two of your buddies,
Tony,
Tony's C e l a N.
O.
Solano.
Yeah.
L.
I a n l a C e.
A.
N.
O.
Solano.
Yes.
I'm horrible with names and Eric Friedman,
they their tomorrows.
Nobody's,
there's this there they,
they write a bunch of and they draw a bunch of animations.
They're wonderful man.
They said this,
try it out.
They animated the try it out.
It's so funny.
This is not the full thing,
but just take a look at what they did here.
Black guys would love the fuck.
Fuck do y'all man fucking black guy.
You want to fuck men from jail,
homeless or Roger Thug.
Want to come then Franklin Williams.
[inaudible] man three flew.
Three ranch Achilles and the cake.
But you got to fuck when I come up with today and try it out.
Try it out,
man.
If to my beloved tried out and I fucking piss on me beat,
I'm running out to Wyoming as fuck man.
I'm looking at the hardcore guys and meaning to do it by trash.
Come to the fuck.
Amazing.
So good.
It's poetry.
If you,
um,
if you're listening right now,
you have to see this go to youtube page and we'll uh,
we'll put it on the youtube
channel.
Your mom's house pies.
It's really,
really exceptional.
You guys inspire art.
Well,
we,
you know,
the other thing is we've been soliciting people to do their own,
try it out videos.
Um,
so people had been submitted,
I love this black guys who love to fuck and fuck good.
If you're a hot black guy and you want to fuck me at 2029
you got to fuck me.
Fuck a lot.
He does look like you're skipping funny man,
man.
Everything else,
Here's the deal,
man.
Nailed it.
That's a great cold ric brown.
You would nailed the role and you get a call back for sure.
You would get a call.
It looks like it needs dick or he'll die.
We were asking for,
we were like,
oh,
so far last week we had a bunch of submissions,
all men and I was like,
are any women going to submit our,
the women black guys are like,
fuck guy,
black guy and you want to fuck me at 23
I need be fucked a lot.
She's good.
By the way.
I'm big on the teeth.
I'm a big teeth man.
Yeah,
and the space is sexy as shit like that dude,
Bella,
Donna teeth,
right.
Good.
At least Nikki Fuck piss on me.
Beat me home and now
she's at home.
Man.
You know what I like about her by the way?
I've got faith and faith.
Here's why she nailed it.
She did the breaths.
She even got it down to the like his,
his frantic breathing.
That's a really good work phase.
Obviously her acting classes have started to pay off so far.
Uh,
James and faith are both getting called back.
Great lighting guys.
Fuck and fuck good if you were black.
I love to fuck me.
If you want to move in,
you can move in.
But he's got the wrapping paper in the bathroom.
It's got a map.
Free rent free.
Everything else,
man.
Men from jail.
She looks like she's in a crack house.
So I'm done with this.
She's got the,
what is that something that she's holding?
Something has a mustache.
I don't know,
but it's over.
She does a great job.
Really,
really good.
If you want to move in frank and move into man,
fuck me.
Pissed me.
Beat on me.
I'm home right now.
Well,
you guys love to fucking fuck good.
Fuck me at 2195.
You want to hold it?
You free rent,
free food.
Everything else,
man
to jail.
You're homeless.
Your thumb.
Oh
fuck me.
Piss on me.
Beat me.
I'm home
building.
Try it out.
You want to fucking Piss on me?
It
don't fuck hell,
it's fuck.
I gotta tell you I'm blown away.
I mean honestly Ashley,
the Manic Energy,
which she delivered that oof.
You always got to make the roll yours and that's what I saw with these people.
They went a little deeper than just a craigslist creepy fuck.
They go,
what is this person's back story?
What was high school like for this person?
What was their relationship to their father?
Did the family like the fucking fuck now thug hard come over and fuck hard.
You know?
I mean it was a different interpretation yet it worked because the energy,
the frenetic energy and the anxiety was there.
I felt it.
Couple more females.
Let's,
I could see her like in a,
fuck me.
Fuck me now on ice like ice version of that.
I could definitely see that happening.
Yeah.
She killed him.
You might actually send her out first.
Let's get the show stuff.
Go out there.
The whole arena.
You want to fuck?
Oh
fuck me.
Fuck me.
Fuck.
She took her shirt off.
She,
this is like a Cinemax friction.
Everything else,
men.
And here's the deal,
man in jail,
homeless,
want to come move in.
Moving to men.
This is really good.
This is Kelsey.
She also committed,
she did a,
I feel like a commitment to a different drug than the words.
It feels more sedated.
Okay.
Eva,
but maybe sativa,
maybe like a real,
I don't know,
more excessive,
more powerful downer,
but the eyes black tar.
Yeah.
I'm like more of a black tar feel.
I feel like the eyes are really selling it for me.
I love your mustache.
Obviously her pacing is very slow shirt off detail also.
Yeah.
You know when you do these auditions and you submit these things,
it's all about details because God's in the details and if you're a black guy
likes to fuck and like fuck hard,
you know,
I've got to feel that in your video.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's true.
I got to feel it.
It's also a brave choice.
What the fuck black guys who lopped off fucking unbelievable.
And you want to fuck
and the bow.
You know what I feel like this is like backstage a Larry the cable guy concert.
We're like,
we're like backstage.
He's just a dude.
And then yeah,
the Larry,
the cable guy,
eyes come in and now he's the character.
Well that's what I felt.
She did something amazing.
She started,
she started her clip by saying she's Peyton Lafferty who is another go to from
the show.
Oh sorry.
So she did that.
Oh Shit.
And then she went into the time that she actually switched person.
She went,
she went from like hi and then she's doing this really well.
I think she's active and,
and you know what I like,
her posture is exactly his,
she even got the bow,
the attention to detail.
Yeah.
I wonder how much she paid for like a lighting crew.
The light,
the scene for her and,
and the lighting went from like well lit to like Kramer.
Yeah.
Very Good Edward.
It's competitive.
Competitive.
It is.
And if you don't put the time and effort in,
you're not going to make the shift.
This is Chris,
this chick's great.
Jail,
homeless,
great.
She's obviously Armenian.
She's a woman with a mustache,
so those are my people.
That's my mom's mom.
She's,
she's,
she's very good at mimicking,
I think.
Very close.
Very good.
Moving Franco.
Moving to man.
She's got the accent.
Yeah,
piss on me.
Beat me.
Oh Man.
Out.
Try it out,
man.
Your dawn and try it out.
You want to fucking piss on me.
You've literally gone through more or less female listeners and all my podcasts.
Now here's the thing.
As with the Yani,
Laurel,
I'm now,
I'm hearing home man.
Now of course it's like it goes back and forth.
Your brain is primed to,
that's why we just live in a simulation,
man.
Yup.
Black guys who love to fuck and fuck good.
If you're hot black guy and you want to fuck the at two,
three,
nine,
five,
if you want to move,
you've got to fuck me.
I fucked a lot.
He's like the Guy Ritchie version of it,
you know?
Can I tell you something?
All I keep thinking about it is like this video getting out there on its own
with obviously near context and guys watching this being like,
we have got to find this thick,
this Lauren,
because this is exactly the video I've wanted to see my whole life.
Like a woman who's like,
guys who want to fuck,
I'm down if you want to piss on me.
Oh yeah.
And Are you one more magical than British black guys?
Like Guy Ritchie films.
They have all the answers.
Whatever you don't know about life,
they fill it in.
It's so much better.
Me have been a Pelletreau doing a British accent.
Like she's got that refinement.
Very clean and crisp.
It's a Shakespeare in love version.
What better way to honor the royal wedding then to push them to get their on by
black guys.
Men from jail,
jail,
jail.
Sounds like a wonderful place where she's from.
Your friend can move into free rent.
You get at least in a cage.
She goes like casual,
piss on me,
beat me.
Have you guys ever been peed on?
How would you say great.
Have you gotten,
by the way?
We're talking about,
have you gone to adult con before?
I've gone every time.
Please.
Let's do it.
I got peed on by Miley Cyrus,
his stunt double.
Of course she did,
but so,
so,
uh,
do you remember the British,
the uh,
American music awards?
It was many moons ago and Miley Cyrus is dancing on stage and then she runs down
the aisle and then the camera turns and Miley is sitting there in her seat.
Well,
that girl who runs down the thing peed on me one time.
We were at the comedy store and seeing you at the store.
Well,
she tried,
it got like this weird like deer hunting fucking thing went on.
What was she hammered?
She wasn't,
she just somebody,
she somehow brought up peeing and she's like,
I'll pee on you.
And then it got really weird and everybody's laying money down.
So then we're all in the back and nothing happened.
Where were you when you got peed on?
I was in the shower of the green room of the main room.
Okay.
And did you strip down or I just took my shirt off.
And she peed on your chest?
No,
she couldn't.
So then she's like,
Oh,
I really want pee on you.
I'm like,
well let's go back to my place.
He could pee on me.
So we go back to my place and I,
I,
you know,
I'd take the shop.
She peed on me.
It's wonderful.
And then I get up and she starts putting on her clothes and I'm like,
what are you doing dude?
Like are you putting it,
why are you putting in your life?
She's like,
we're going to have sex.
I'm like,
I'm not a Porta potty.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I like,
yeah.
So I actually do enjoy it.
Oh,
so and then you,
you told her?
Yes.
And then she's like,
oh,
okay.
I will have sex with you.
And then smooth.
Right.
Like what did her piece smell?
A lot of showered after.
I'm not a scumbag,
but I did.
I'm not against it.
They,
after she peed on you,
you showered and then you had sex?
No.
Take me,
I'm sorry to ask a lot of details,
but can you take me through,
let's talk about where did you lay that?
Where you lay in your bathtub?
Yes.
Okay.
And then does she squat over you?
Ah,
yes.
Um,
and like facing new,
no.
Sh Ah,
no,
he was an asshole towards my face and like very close or like,
you know,
far up.
I didn't know.
She wasn't like right here.
She's like here like,
you know,
I was in the tub,
there's a tub she's on,
had foot on both sides holding boom.
And then yeah,
Pete and some of that Bennett is she like,
um,
I like it that she laughing door during it and he's just like,
you know,
she's happy.
She,
she achieved something.
Get in the tub naked in the tub.
I W I had my,
I think I was naked actually because I was in the tub.
It was going to get all over the place.
What I thought so did it get in your mouth?
Nose more of my chest,
but I wouldn't be against that cause it didn't smell strong.
No,
no,
it was excellent.
He is.
Yeah.
I mean like peeing on people.
It was like not drinking more.
Who was,
who was like a shower?
Golden.
Yeah.
He's like,
yeah,
dude.
I guess I'm just a Weirdo.
I can see how it's pleasurable.
What about eating poop though?
I don't eat poop.
I don't,
but I love eating,
but,
but I don't like poop.
No.
You made sure the booties clean.
Yeah.
You got to do a quick look.
Just get in there like a champion,
Ui it out for it and then I finger blasts,
which is,
I call it the Avatar.
Remember when they sync up with the a flying animal and the other soul mates.
That's why back in the day,
this is young Tripoli.
Now I just want to sleep.
Yeah.
Have you ever had anyone take a shit on?
You know,
that will never happen.
That's just not my thing.
It's to McAfee.
Is that his name?
Yeah.
John McAfee.
Mcafee.
Oh,
he's into that?
Yeah,
it is.
Oh really?
Oh,
it's just not my thing too.
I can't even entertain it.
It's a lot.
Yeah.
Hooping in the mouth.
I don't know how you keep from vomiting.
Really.
Oh,
do the smell of like fresh cumin shit.
just throw hook.
Get me Outta here.
I was watching,
uh,
I laugh by the way we were talking about women's bathrooms versus meds and she
was saying how like women,
you know,
we'll like squeeze their butts on the dumper.
And I was in lax yesterday and I walked in,
it was like,
oh gosh,
and need get almost embarrassed.
Like,
oh so well you're like,
ah,
sorry.
You know,
it's like a symphony out your asshole.
It really is.
And like those bathrooms are wrecked,
man.
Lax.
I just feel like the women's poop doesn't smell as bad as guys.
That's right.
It's a completely,
completely wrong.
It's smells horrendous.
It's the same thing.
It's shit.
Shit is shit.
We eat the same things.
Right.
What do you spray after?
Cause back in the day when I worked at the store,
the best place to meet chicks were sitting next to the women's bathroom and it
came out.
It was never like I was ever like,
it's not that this shit doesn't stick.
We don't Shit at the comedy store.
Women are more weary of shitting in public is what I'm saying,
that it's the fear of embarrassment and of the smell.
So we'll shit here at home,
but not out in public.
You guys are just animals.
We are scumbags.
So disgusting were knuckle draggers.
Oh,
for sure.
What are you guys kinky?
Kinky couple.
You guys just like Mormon eyeball
for stroke gang?
Yeah,
pretty much.
Nothing wrong with that.
I'm definitely less strokes than I used to be.
I just feel like sex is like to stroke.
People talk a big game.
They talk like I'm going to do this,
I'm gonna do this.
And then just at the end it's like bump,
bump,
dump,
go sleep.
Then that's part of the married thing too is like,
you know you have your,
your big tricks and performance when you're,
when you're starting out,
you show the first show time,
dude throws out all the tricks.
Right.
Got To get repeat business,
got to get her to come back for another Starbucks coffee.
So you throw all the good shit.
All of it.
Yeah,
man.
And from there it's like you have,
um,
you know your performance face on.
So you're like,
you're like,
what is your performance from saying?
He's like,
you're like,
you're like intense and you're like,
flip,
flip.
You're doing positions and you're like,
yeah,
this is what I do.
Tom,
do you fuck with your eyes open or close?
Like to concentrate or you just like stare into her soul?
What is it?
Well,
right now I'm seven months pregnant,
so there's limited thing.
There's not a lot you can do at this point.
It's,
you know what I mean?
Like it's side meet time.
Mommy.
No,
no,
not doggy style.
No,
I can't say we tried last pregnancy remmeber
and I couldn't stay up.
I was too heavy.
It's too heavy.
It's like regular when there's no,
when there's no thing.
I don't know.
I'm not like put her in the Gay Barbara Swing Doc.
I put her in,
I tried to down all the time.
I might try now.
Try not try now.
Try hard.
Try.
Good.
Let's finish Lauren.
That I love her accent.
Yeah,
she's doing great.
It's dying and try it out.
Try it out.
This is like Peter Pan trying to fucking try it out to the black guys.
Try Out.
You want to fucking Piss on me?
Try out serious replies.
Only just fuck me.
I'm looking for hardcore guys and mean it and want to do it and I want it
delivered.
I'm a hot white trash come done.
That's fantastic.
Shakespeare and also it was a different,
she made it her own.
Yes,
she,
she really did her own thing.
I always tell people that when it comes to the industry,
they don't know what they want.
These people let you know what they want and therefore you know where you want
to,
what they want.
As as the director,
I would right now be talking to my producers like I really liked what Loren did.
It was different.
It was,
yeah.
Yeah.
You know,
I thought it was entertaining.
It caught my eye,
caught my eye.
Do you know that our European women come to America to get drilled by like black
guys?
Like they try,
they come here.
Why will this one too?
Okay.
Put that down on,
no.
Talking about black mayors the last,
try it out.
Sammy whole model.
There's black guys in Europe.
Are you talking?
Yeah,
but they want like fucking American black.
Okay.
And they also spend their money.
They want to short American comedians.
They spend their money,
they go crazy when they're young and hot.
Are you ready for this?
Ready for theories with AAA?
Okay,
hold on.
Okay.
What is it?
Somebody submitted a tried out song.
Oh Great.
Good.
Yeah.
Who loved to fuck.
Fuck.
And you want to fuck me at 23
she could sing
really well.
That's great.
Amanda.
F and m move in
always with our show
food.
Everything else.
Men,
men,
men from jail,
homeless.
Um,
you wanna come.
Moving.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
Hello.
Good to set up talent.
Florence.
The machine.
That's what I'm sensing right now.
Some may me.
Oh man,
this could be a song.
This awesome.
It looks like somewhat of a hostage situation as well.
You know what I could see like Fiona apple doing torture,
like piss on shore.
You,
my ex boyfriend's a piece of shit like that kind of
bells inside.
What was that band from like the early two thousands they were big and then they
just went away like dido or like this is one of those,
I'm totally break up songs.
Yeah,
I love it.
Um,
I don't know who you're a guitar player is Amanda,
but amazing voice and really,
really interesting,
a beautiful rendition of this.
And I love the background.
She paid attention to the lighting,
the details.
Imagine if they try it out guy,
how can you get these to him and let him know like he's inspired so much hard.
Oh my God,
that would be a dream.
It's a c that's it.
Have a camera on him.
No,
showing him.
Oh,
what is this?
Just took off and then like 20 years later he's just like,
everybody walks him,
hey dude,
I tried to,
no,
I don't give them,
cause I'm at the,
I met the guy like a,
what was the Sharman they don't squeeze the Charmin.
And I remember seeing him.
I go,
hey dude,
I don't squeeze.
Sharmy goes,
I don't give a fuck what you do with the Sharman.
Okay.
You think I give a fuck?
And I'm like,
oh dude,
you must hear this.
The time you,
and he would hear that all the time if you were that guy.
Oh,
I don't get,
I try it out.
You can try out shoved up your ass once you six oh seven.
That shit.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Buddy's head.
Um,
ever since you introduced hot white Meth,
come guide to your clip lexicon.
I no longer enjoy any type of self pleasure.
Now that vision of Mr Math and his voice haunts my spank bank.
Never again will I be alone with my thoughts.
Haunting.
You're out in closing.
You're awesome.
Keep up the good work.
Come to Pensacola and talk trash about occasions.
We love you.
Cheers Taylor.
Yeah,
I mean,
I know it.
I've been thinking about that guy and I also think about trying it out.
Guy,
whenever anybody says,
why don't you try this out now it's ruined.
Yep.
Try it.
I'll try it out.
You see,
you saw the video of the lady in the Tim Horton's?
Uh,
no.
My fuck.
We gotta talk about this,
but let me remind you,
yeah,
we have eight dental uptake coming up saying,
oh yeah,
yeah,
we do have to get that ready.
Um,
and this should be on TV.
You guys should have this show on television.
I don't know.
I'd watch it.
Coca Cola or General Electric who are show showtime the shit.
Try it out.
Show time.
Showtime photo here.
This show I showed the HB all this would be perfect.
Netflix is Netflix for sure.
Try it out.
Yeah.
What's up Netflix?
Oh No,
wait.
So what was I about to tell you that you're going to show us tomorrow?
Yeah.
Holy Macro.
My God.
This video went a tad viral,
at least in our world.
I had friends sending this like,
do you just get inundated with
like,
you guys are somewhat the Worldstar hip hop of podcasting.
Yeah.
Like you get sent the best of the best.
Yeah,
we do.
We do.
We're lucky.
Lucky our fans really do all this,
this podcast,
eight years,
and it's just humming with greatness.
You get better and better.
I think the clips are getting where the world is.
So that's why you guys are doing so well because you feel so good about where
you are in life compared to like what's going on out there in the world.
You're like,
oh dude,
we're not trying it out.
Try now.
Try.
Yeah,
we're definitely ahead of the try it out.
Yeah.
Yeah,
man.
Um,
options before I forget.
Tell me,
I don't want to forget until too late in the show.
Where can people see you coming up?
Well,
I'm very excited that,
uh,
live nation and all things comedy is producing the tinfoil hat comedy night at
Cobb's June 1st.
Oh,
that's great.
Myself,
Eddie Bravo.
[inaudible] off the grid.
Ryan and then we're going to be in Sacramento.
Uh,
June 2nd there one shows each and I'm super,
I'm excited,
man.
Oh,
go see Sammy live.
He's one of the best.
Talk about Lizard people,
weirdness like that.
I love it.
[inaudible] it's gonna be,
I'm really excited about.
So you'll have the table up there,
right?
And the,
we're going to do stand up.
Okay.
And then we're going to do a Q and a at the,
oh,
that's so you're getting double trouble.
Yeah.
You know what?
There's one thing that's so great about when you do a one show night somewhere
where it just breathe easy and people know that like we're going to settle in to
like,
it's just for us,
the one show nights,
the show's been tinfoil hats been killing it lately,
man.
It's been a lot of fun.
I've learned a lot about the world and it's,
I just enjoy it.
Good man for you to perfect for it.
Sam Aaa.
Such a fantastic standup comic if you want to see him.
He's also on my show May 31st at the comedy store in the belly room,
the eight o'clock show.
So excited.
I just small show.
I'm running my Netflix set,
uh,
for the Vegas shooting June 4th.
And you're going to get to see Sam Tripoli as well.
So try it out.
And then you did my Dojo room is so much fun.
You gotta do what you do at a few nights a week.
He runs every night,
every night in Los Angeles.
At the Sycamore Tavern in Hollywood.
It's a fantastic comedy show.
Uh,
drinks right free parking.
Parking's x,
gives work it out.
That's really what I created the room for us.
Just somewhere like you don't have to fall like monsters and you can just try to
work something now.
It's a great room.
And Sam,
he shot his new special yup.
Viper Room.
Editing it right now.
Super excited about it.
I'm going to edit it as one piece and then also break it into two pieces.
Like two 40 fives.
Wow.
Look at you with some bonus jokes at the end that I forgot to do that.
I just want to add your shopping at home for it right now a while.
Once it's edited,
all things.
Comedy wants to bring it up so I'm cool wherever it goes.
If it goes somewhere cool or put out myself,
I'm just kind of why I just want to start creating shit.
Throw it out.
You don't care.
That's the way to do it.
People are going to love it when they see I'm a crazy person.
I like just,
I like to just do my own thing.
You know,
what I like about Sam is that you really don't give a fuck.
And I feel like,
especially in this era of people being censored and afraid to say things,
it's so important to have comedians like you out there.
Uh,
really try.
You know what I'm saying?
Like really keeping it real and being an hardcore guys who want to fucking fuck.
Yeah,
I want to fuck,
I want to fuck good,
I want to fuck now.
And I just feel that it's just like,
you know,
my career is what it is.
I don't really care to do the Hollywood thing anymore.
Don't get me wrong.
If they offered it,
I'd probably do it.
But I just feel like we have so many comedians selling each other out and just
let it,
like just joining this mob.
And I just feel like comedians have to be able to fail and say provocative shit
and just go for it and not be like blackball I just don't get this world of like
black balling comics because you didn't like a joke.
And I think we let the meek pick the rules.
I feel like political correctness is like letting the,
the fat kid who gets picked last and kickball,
uh,
make the rules of the playground.
It makes no sense to me.
Yeah.
I feel like the joke,
wait,
leave,
do whatever you want.
But she like,
Dude,
stop telling people what they can.
And especially comics who are like,
oh,
do Dutch is,
you shouldn't say that.
Why would you ever want to limit yourself?
Why?
I don't get it.
No,
it's ridiculous.
I know.
And it's,
it is heartbreaking when it's comedians that are policing.
What are you do?
Is these Beta cook,
these Beta Cox to the Beta male,
the Beta Cox,
what they're trying to do is outrage themselves through their dreams.
That's really what they're trying to do.
They're trying to get rid of everybody that they're threatened by so they can
just walk right into their dreams.
Don't realize that everybody's got dreams.
Yeah.
And you won't make your dreams.
You've got to take someone else's dreams and like,
it's not going to be easy like that.
Those are some wise words from Sam Aaa.
Right.
Very true.
A lot of people are,
um,
they rail against people.
They feel threatened by it.
Absolutely.
This business for sure,
the powerful,
the winners and they want to drag down.
My French is getting in trouble for this fucking tweet and it's just like the,
it's like you said that I could sing a white males are the new n word.
It's a bad joke.
It's a,
it's not a good joke,
but he's like,
he's got black balled from this club and guess who's yelling at him?
White Beta Cox.
That's his genre.
It's not black guys or black women going crazy.
Beta Cox.
That's the next shirt.
Tom Beta Cox.
I love Beta cock.
That's great.
That's gotta be your next shirt.
Sam.
You should,
I'm going to go,
I mean,
just go,
oh,
I'm so tired of it.
Of these meat.
And then you got,
you know,
all these male feminists who in Hollywood we find out are all the ones doing all
the raping.
Yeah.
Right?
Yes.
It's not the knuckle draggers.
Yeah.
No,
not the saddle ranch bartenders.
They're doing all this shit.
That's right.
Yeah.
The ones with the big mouth piece that they're so fucking look at Cosby telling
everybody how to live.
What a scummy dad.
He's the most evil of the fucking all of them.
Yeah.
I know Matt Lauer that fucking Homo too.
I mean come on,
but he's hit like Matt Lauer is looking to make a comeback.
Comeback from a fucking,
basically a rape button like hit a rape button in is nobody wants a now back
from any of those.
No.
Nobody gives a,
I don't want to and see Chris to that fucking ass kisser.
Well,
he didn't get,
he didn't get checked at all.
No,
none.
You know why?
Because the me too movement ended up taking out their own people.
Do you know what I'm saying?
They thought it was going to lead to like taking out all these politicians and
it just ended up taking out everybody at the Golden Globes.
Yeah.
They're like,
whoa.
Then it just started ruining brands,
so they're like,
okay,
we got it.
Jay,
just stop.
Nobody's getting harassed anymore.
No,
no.
By the way.
I think that that tweet though that,
that Josh then,
yeah,
it was really just,
it was just,
um,
I think he was trying to make a point that he didn't word correctly at all.
Right.
And that,
that's really,
I mean,
that's just why people flip.
Well,
we got to be able to,
you know,
you gotta be able to fail and,
and you don't want to just like this notion that he's like trying to bring back
like Alabama and the 1950s it's just ridiculous and it's just white people going
crazy on other white people.
Remember that woman that sent a tweet as she was flying to Africa,
she was like,
fine,
Africa,
hope I don't get aids.
Lol.
And by the time she had landed,
yeah,
she had been fired from her job,
Twitter blown her up and she like,
her life was ruined in a matter of hours from like a dumb joke that she kind of
thought like,
hey,
it's off color.
It's not great.
It's just a thought.
Twitter supposed to be like math throw away.
Yeah.
And her life is ruined.
It doesn't work like that anymore.
No,
it's amazing cement.
He moved.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Um,
you know,
that's the other thing about things written that stay there cause you can read
it over and you oh yeah,
they fall tweets from him from 2008.
Yeah.
From fruit for Josh Denny.
They went back to 2008.
Here's the thing,
man.
Entertainers,
they're crazy people.
Yeah.
And they like crazy weird shit.
And if you,
if you make it so we can't be crazy weird,
you're just going to get liars.
Yeah.
And that's the whole point of comedy is like,
to be as honest as you can on stage,
but when you pull up old tweets from any comic,
you're going to find a wasteland because that's how jokes are written.
You write the thing normally it's not publicly.
And then if,
you know,
if you go through it,
most comedians joke books,
you'd be like,
oh my God.
Yeah.
Because it takes time to work out swings and you're like,
I missed the mark on this.
This is horribly offensive because really like great jokes are,
are
usually like on the line.
It's like you find the line and you dance on the line.
If you don't get to do that,
you,
you know,
then you just,
you just never,
right.
What ends up happening is you go over the line a lot when you're trying to
figure something out,
right.
And then you go,
that's too much.
So people don't laugh and you have to pull,
but you have to be able to try to figure out the line to be able to fail.
And you're like,
you can't tell me to celebrate our diversity and then tell me I can't comment on
it.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like Dave Chappelle is one of the funniest dudes ever.
The first 30 minutes.
I like the first 50 minutes of one this special on Netflix.
All rape jokes.
Yeah,
but where's the outrage on that?
And I love Dave Chappelle.
I don't know why you got it.
Yeah,
but it wasn't like the fucking murder you've seen people go after and then their
whole thing with the Donald Glover video where he's like shooting people and
like white people were loved telling everybody what that video was about.
But two weeks later that Jay feely takes a picture of his daughter going to the
prom with a gun and everybody loses their skull.
And it's just like,
what are you doing man?
You make it really hard for when real shit hits the fan to anybody.
Give a shit.
Well,
the,
what part of what's going on is that everybody has a voice now.
That's what social media has allowed.
It's given everybody a platform.
So it makes people feel powerful.
They get to express that rage and when a lot of them get together,
you know,
it seems like a movement.
Yeah,
totally.
But it only matters if they can affect the money behind whatever's happened.
That's true.
So if they can rally your employer,
the General Electric,
whatever is sponsoring this thing or that,
then it matters.
It doesn't fucking matter unless it's going to affect the revenue stream tied to
it.
It's always money.
Yeah.
I don't like,
I don't like when anybody from it,
I'm saying any,
um,
side of the aisle,
any ideology,
uh,
gets their,
um,
ability to work destroyed from their jokes or,
you know what I mean?
Like when,
when when somebody makes a a joke and then people are like start attacking.
Yeah,
their ability to make a loop.
It's like what is the point of that?
Yeah,
I think that's right.
I think that's a very place to anger and it's just like what you're trying to do
is make the Batman go away and that's not life.
That's just not life.
Now
argue that that's a problem with the me too movement is that the bad men just
don't go away.
Sweeties it doesn't just go away.
So we need to have a discussion about the gray areas,
not just the black and the why.
You can't just Shawn,
right?
We window throw him in a fire pit and blow up all the rapists and the
pedophiles.
They're still gonna fucking exist.
So what do we do now?
There is a,
there is something about Hollywood as no different than Washington DC and,
and Wall Street.
And you know,
if you're lucky to make it through a medium,
like you guys were able to create this amazing medium of this podcast which took
you to the certain levels that you didn't necessarily have to go through that,
you know,
auditioning all the shit to get through.
That almost takes a psychopath level of dedication.
There's craziness.
Yeah.
So when you get there,
you are a cycle path.
It is no different than Woelfel Wall Street shit.
True.
Like the,
you meet the high thigh
bay,
they just,
they're just crazy piece sheer force of will.
I mean you,
yeah,
of course.
So then they get there in a course they're going to want to scorch the earth.
Right.
And a lot of these guys like couldn't get any,
couldn't get laid in high school.
So everything I learned about women,
they learned by watching Japanese anime porn.
Right?
So they think girls like octopus tentacles all in fucking places and it's just
like no wonder they're psychopaths.
Yeah.
All right,
let's go to the next time.
Sammy.
Here's what we're going to now.
There's no audio cause this is from a security camera.
That's where this lady is,
that I'm a crazy person.
You're the best guest ever.
Look,
this woman is really animated yelling at the employees in Canada,
right?
Yeah.
At Tim Horton's.
That's like their Dunkin donuts.
Right?
And she's yelling at him,
yelling,
yelling.
Oh my God.
Don't do it.
Oh my God,
wait,
wait this way of what you're seeing.
So,
so yeah,
we,
for people listening,
this lady was extremely,
extremely animated,
clearly yelling at the man behind the counter at this Tim Horton's.
Okay.
She,
um,
she then runs over,
or excuse me,
walks over to the Napkin dispenser,
Grabs Napkins,
keeps yelling at him.
You can basically put together that he is,
he's very calmly and politely saying,
he's Canadian.
Yes.
He's very Canadian.
Like saying you have to leave.
She keeps yelling.
Takes the a sweater that is wrapped around her waist,
off,
drops her pants,
leans against the wall and takes a big shit like,
uh,
my dad type shit.
Like,
and by the way,
Christina,
you're totally right.
Women dropped the hot deuce too.
I mean,
it's like,
it's hail just came out of her that,
you know,
how you get sometimes juiced up and the adrenaline rush and then like you have
to irritate,
like post dump comedy chats.
Oh yeah.
Was comedy dumps this thing?
She had one on deck.
We have to surmise that what's happening is that she probably asked to use the
restroom,
right as they say as they say,
washroom to wash clothes and uh,
in,
in Canada,
uh,
customers only probably,
I assume when I saw it the first time.
Uh,
but then again,
the fact that it's Canada makes me think differently.
I don't know.
I just felt like,
well,
it depends on where you are.
The big problem in Hollywood is that nobody,
they really don't like using public bathrooms because people go in there and do
drugs and then they don't open the door for fucking ever.
Yeah.
So that's why they like Starbucks forever.
I remember being,
by the way,
a new comic,
uh,
Sam triple,
he got me into it and uh,
you know,
trying to,
trying to work out bits and one of my like old school bits,
they never went.
You know,
one of those you kind of throw out there was about trying to use a public
restroom in Hollywood.
It's so hard and also it feels inhumane,
right?
That you can go like,
Hey,
I need to,
I'm a human being and I need to pee right now.
And they're like,
you can go somewhere else.
You can't go here.
Not here.
Nope.
Nope,
no public bathrooms.
Uh,
your,
your place of cells,
uh,
liquor,
like,
ah,
Glick our coffee.
This is,
wait,
this is United States of America and I,
I can't go pee right now.
Drop a deuce.
Yeah,
I have to go.
And they're like,
well,
it's not for you.
It's,
yeah,
it's really crazy that you built a narrative like that.
I just thought she was fired up about something else.
She's a crazy person.
You might be right.
You might hear this was a math training and this was her way of retaliating.
And being like,
fuck you dude.
I want Sammy to take a call from here,
so I'm going to start playing clip number two of this,
which picks up right here.
You go ahead and describe what you see.
Okay,
here we go.
So,
so then she,
oh my God,
she,
she zoom monkeys it,
she grabbed up.
By the way,
the whole poop poop is gone.
I just realized that there's no poop left on that floor.
She literally cleaned it up for him.
She grabbed it and that poop state heart,
which made it hard and quick,
which makes me think hi.
It's some oexman shit going on.
Like her super powers that she drops deuces and places and she uses as a weapon.
She dropped it.
There's no poop on the floor.
Which this guy who's drinking his coffee,
he's like,
thank God,
right?
Yeah,
he sits there and wouldn't you get up?
I don't think he knows what's going on because of that wall.
He knows there's some action going on.
But Sandy,
she picked up her shit and it's gone.
She threw it at the guy like a boomerang style.
Then she wiped her ass and through that paper at the guy too.
Man,
she just really hates this coffee.
That's what this got to be.
She wants Starbucks is the only got Tim Horton's.
There was audio.
If anybody has the audio file,
please send it in.
I would just love to hear that poop hit again.
She got some solid lows.
I've dude,
I was blown away.
That whole poop state together.
It dead.
It wasn't like a five perfect five.
Does that mean she's healthy if your pool,
so this is obviously not drug addict.
This might be like a crossfit lady who just wanted to drop a deuce and they're
like,
oh sorry.
It's for customers only.
She's like,
Oh really?
Boom,
eat my fucking whey protein.
Check this out.
I just pulled this up.
Oh,
audio.
No.
What she has on,
first of all she had was on athletic pants like PyLadies pants and then the
thing,
I think she's like a mom who came from [inaudible] telling me what it says.
Angry.
It says,
we finally know why the angry Tim Horton's Pooper pooped for the love of God.
Just let people use your bathroom.
In recent days.
This has become the deep in the bowels of a mystery.
Why does the woman take of Dublin and British Columbia?
Tim Horton's,
if you haven't heard about this,
uh,
this is my only question.
Is,
is how,
how soon too.
She's headlining Improv.
Um,
she then grab Napkins.
Yes.
Picked up her log.
Here's,
we have the answer.
It turns out the Timmies employees wouldn't let her use the bathroom and she
really,
really had to go fucking it mean to Morton's restroom policy is that anyone can
use it.
You don't have to be a customer,
but that in some franchises employees have to give you a keys or buzz you into
the bathroom at their discretion.
On Thursday,
Tim Horton's responded to the video.
The statement,
the fast food chain said they didn't let it use me.
Use the bathroom because of past behavior and past behavior,
out of concern for the immediate say to team members and guests in the
restaurant.
We are deeply concerned by this video,
blah,
blah.
And in limited cases we restrict a bathroom policies.
So she had gone in there and made a fool of herself.
Excuse me before.
Is that what I mean?
That's what that implies.
A police picked her up.
She was eventually released.
She's coming to,
she's going to make a court appearance coming up and she'll be headlining.
Yuck.
In Calgary.
She was that,
what was the other public defecation.
Wait a minute.
This is,
or this is a open defecation open up.
It is open application.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
What was the name of that?
Um,
there's Yaki ox and there's house of comedy.
Yeah,
she,
right,
right.
No,
there's a
comedy.
What is the one in Edmonton?
Fuck,
I can't believe I can't remember the name.
I love the club dude.
I do.
I shot a special there.
Um,
I don't know.
Comedy fucking comedy,
comedy,
comedy committee.
Gambit.
I was told the guy,
oh,
runs Yuk.
Yuks hates female comics.
That's why I never played there.
Blows my mind that people do this.
I was told that like a decade ago.
Like,
no,
he just hates females and like believable.
Yes.
I won't be doing Canada for so many funny females out there and now it's
pathetic.
Anyway,
it really is a lot.
Um,
dental update,
man.
Oh,
you're totally right.
But see these teeth,
let's see,
let's see.
Here is my dental update.
Sammi I'm a big snorer.
Um,
when I started dating Christina,
I wasn't snoring and then I got real fat and I started snoring a lot.
That's men do that.
And one day she played me a recording of my snoring.
Oh really?
This is when we were engaged and I swear to you,
it was like somebody,
it was like somebody playing a video of you drunk and they're going,
this is what you're like when you're drinking.
You're like,
oh my God,
I have to quit drinking today.
It was like that where I was so ashamed that I ordered a,
uh,
a snore guard,
like an online one that night.
Then I went to the dentist a few months later and I had like a,
a real deal one,
well,
they're made a plastic,
obviously their mouth guards over time they start to change color and it starts
to look like you.
Keep your snore guard in a trash bag and then you pull it out when you want to
sleep.
So mine got to the point where it's pretty discolored now and it looks gross two
years though.
Yeah,
it's a few years old and I asked that that he was like,
he said,
it's totally normal.
He goes,
you know,
they look,
retainers get scummy too after awhile.
So I just have my new one delivered yesterday.
How was I last night?
Not a peep.
Okay.
Yeah.
I called d four station where it sounds like you're just cutting trees down.
That's me,
my girlfriend.
Go back and forth.
Do you wear a guard?
Nothing,
dude.
You know,
here's,
here's the thing.
You think when you get it,
like when I first ordered the one over the,
yeah,
over the internet or whatever online,
you're like,
I'm just doing this to save her the burden of having to let her sleep once in a
while.
That's the only reason I would do.
And it's saying for love,
what happens is you don't realize that snoring,
when you snore horrifically,
you're having a lower quality sleep.
So when you wear this thing,
not only is it quieter for you,
your getting better sleep,
you start to feel more refreshed.
Yeah,
you should really get one.
I'm not against it.
I mean it's,
you know,
you know what the principal is of a,
so if you lay on your back right now,
I pretend you're asleep.
That's exactly right.
See how your lower jaw dropped?
Yeah.
That's what causes a lot of people snoring.
The jaw drops,
your tongue sits back,
your throat meat starts to go in on your air valve.
These guards just keep your lower jaw up.
So when you're totally passed out like this,
your jaw stays up.
Wow.
Air Passage stays open.
Did you sleep so much better just to keep that quality sleep?
Yeah.
Will you try it?
I will.
I think you'll be much happier.
Where do I get it?
Well,
I mean,
I went,
I did mine by just going to the dentist and just telling them,
hey,
I want this done and they take a mold of your top and bottom teeth and then I'm
going to go get a physical done and I'll get that done.
Dude.
Tell me how much better you're sleeping.
I will.
I will report back.
You'll feel like I'm going to try it and you'll get my girlfriend wind throw one
in her mouth.
Yeah.
Throwing my dog.
My dog snores.
What kind of dog is it?
It's a Mutt.
It's a mix.
It's a flat face.
Like these guys.
No,
no,
no.
She's a half percent.
She's half percent g half Thai ridgeback.
The girl here,
Betsy,
she snores like a 300 pound men.
Yeah.
She's just like cranking it out.
Oh yeah.
And then it sounds like chains house,
right?
Yeah.
Cause it'll be like,
and then she like catch herself and I'm like fuck,
I want to throw her in another room.
She sleep on your beds.
They've slept on our beds for years during the pregnancy.
She's much more sensitive to,
you know,
everything.
So we have crates in the room and we were putting them in the crates.
My dog sleeps on our bed and she sleeps perpendicular and we work around her.
Oh yeah.
I'd pay for fucking everything and I've got to work around this dog.
Oh yeah,
no,
no.
These,
I mean sometimes
when they sleep on the bed,
you know,
they'll take turns going between like lane between her legs and then come over,
lay between my legs,
lay next to me.
And you're always like,
yeah,
there's such adorable,
there's just snoring right over here.
I love dogs.
Yeah,
the best man.
I'm a big dog person.
Um,
so tell me how,
tell me the tin foil hat show,
how long have you been going down on it?
Cause I'm a little over a year and it's going strong student.
Great man.
You know,
it's getting hitting marks,
it's growing every day and it's just fun.
I'm not just like,
and it lets you be crazy.
I just enjoy hearing it all.
And you're kind of like learning how to interview people because conspiracy
theorists or like street dogs,
they'd been beaten down a lot that they're very sensitive.
So I kind of just have this thing where it's like,
I'm assuming everything you are saying you believe in,
I just want to hear what you believe.
So I kind of go with instead of just like checking everybody all the time.
I mean if it's a really crazy thing I'll go,
okay,
I don't necessarily believe you checked.
What have you checked that you're like,
ah,
come on.
Well you know it's like I had this guy come on,
there's this thing within the conspiracy community called Q anonymous.
He's been dropping breadcrumbs about all the shit going on with Trump and the
CIA and all.
It's like so excited.
Like if you get into conspiracies,
this is the golden era of conspiracy.
I'm sure.
I'm sure it is the best.
And then gotten into the Annunaki.
So you,
but you do question this dude when someone says something like this.
Yeah,
well it's like this 85 year old man comes on start and he's like,
tell me all about the Annunaki and all this stuff.
So it's like,
I just like to hear it okay to,
I've heard crazy stories from you lizard people.
I'm into that of your family.
So I was going to ask you is like you're telling me like stories about,
yeah POVs whatever brother.
What do they think of your,
are they conspiracy types or are they like I just did an episode with my dad and
which we talked about conspiracies and he's totally into it.
He is,
he's all dude.
He told me very young,
don't believe anything you see and half full.
Don't believe anything you hear and half of what you see.
So it's always kind of been like my whole thing.
Is he into some big ones?
Oh yeah dude,
like JFK and all that stuff.
You know for me the first conspiracy I knew someone was up was when the iron
sheik got busted with a hacksaw.
Jim Dugan in a car and I'm like,
you guys are supposed to hate each other.
And even though I knew wrestling's fake,
I was like,
okay,
that's craziness.
And then over time there's all this crazy stuff.
What's his,
does he have a JFK lane?
Cause I know there's multiple lanes for the,
you know,
he knew something was up that that's where,
that's where the term conspiracy theory comes from is to,
is to CIA creating the term or basically promoting the term to kind of demonize
anybody who questioned the shooting.
Ah.
And then it's from there.
It's just crazy shit.
I had 11.
You have a uh,
JFK theory just because I feel like that's the most famous,
I think he was killed by the Federal Reserve,
the mob and other CIA altogether.
They all were,
it was a big event actually.
People flew in for it and you know,
then you go to nine 11 and there's all that crazy shit that went on with that.
And then there's just so much.
I just love it,
dude.
I love studying at all.
People love it.
It's fun.
Yeah.
I might get,
some people don't want to hear it and I think some people are kind of afraid,
uh,
what's going on and where the world is.
And that's fine too.
I get it.
You know,
some people like to watch the news,
I like to go and read it.
And just go deep and sure.
Then you see all this crazy shit going on.
I just love it dude.
I just like to hear about it.
We have footage of um,
one of the Sam Tripoli's ex girlfriends was in the news,
so I don't know if you want to comment on her at all.
Oh yeah.
You saw her?
Yeah,
the 65,000.
Yeah.
Texts.
I felt like I met my soul mate and everything was just the way it was and I
thought we would just do what everybody else did and we were just like,
get married and everything would be fine.
But that's not what happened.
Right now,
the valley woman accused of stalking a wealthy businessman is sharing her side
of the story from behind bars.
Police say that she texted the victims tens of thousands of times.
Guys,
this woman says she came from Florida to find love.
Now she claims a man she's accused of stalking is her soulmate because of her
superstitious beliefs and a particular number.
It's following the number 33.
I used to wake up every day and every night at three 33 33
Jacqueline clear adis telling the 12 news about her beliefs tied to the number
33 hmm.
And that's kind of what happens is like the crazy people getting the news and
all the shit.
There's a lot of numerology,
stuff like that.
It's all there,
dude.
If you sit down,
you listen to these people,
it's like crazy shit.
Let's see,
let's see.
I'll click crazy shit.
Got It.
So I kept following the number and he said,
well,
she claims that what led her to a Paradise Valley businessman she met on the
dating app.
Look,
see?
Then I find out he does stuff with the Dead Sea.
The Dead Sea has 33% salt in it.
The common ground between the two,
the same birthday,
convincing her even more that he's her match between the two,
convincing her that he's her match.
Our brothers are both named Jacob and David,
both vegetarians,
but police say the multimillionaire didn't feel the same way.
He called the authorities on her numerous times,
including last month when cops found adis trespassing inside his house,
taking a bath.
And I don't want to talk about that.
That's really wild.
And you're shrinking it.
Someone's home and just take a bath.
Yeah.
Like they,
um,
you know that serial killer,
the one that killed that Versace?
Yeah,
he would,
um,
he killed like five guys,
right?
Yeah.
And one of the things he would do and a lot of the homes just like make
sandwiches.
Really,
that was his thing.
Well,
he would just go in there and like chill out,
see what food they had for he killed them or before.
Um,
well see both,
because sometimes he would arrive and no one,
like,
he was kind of waiting for to get home,
so he would just eat.
I remember when they contacted as a dad,
they're like,
Yah,
any truth to your son is the,
uh,
gay serial killer.
He's like,
he's not gay.
He didn't,
there was a serial killer.
That's great.
You know,
here's the thing.
I,
I lived in Vegas for awhile.
Crazy shit comes in good looking packages.
Yeah.
Like with men for the most part when a man's crazy eight effects.
But for some reason,
great reason women could hide like batshit crazy comes in very fuckable package
just but,
and usually the hotter they are,
I can look at those office though.
Right?
Like you see those eyes and the eyebrows.
It's always in the Brower Brower too.
But,
but you know,
I would know 100% immediately looking at this woman that is dangerous.
So all right,
so this girl is probably like 30 right?
Probably.
Right.
And the guy she's probably hitting on is like 55 and like when you get into the
fifties girls in their twenties and thirties can do no wrong.
You always see these older comics taking these super young female comics on the
road.
She's really funny.
Is She?
Yeah,
she really funny.
We don't have to give examples.
No,
no we won't.
One thing I always think about when somebody breaks into someone's house and
goes and makes food from their fridge,
like would you trust a stranger's fridge?
Just cause so much shit.
And ours is old and outdated.
Like,
how do you know what you can and can't eat?
Sure.
Killer at that point,
I don't know really worried about like fucking calorie intake
at that point.
I'm worried about getting food poisoning or something.
Yeah,
but that's your obsession.
You're like,
oh fuck.
How am I going to get away with murder if I get food poisoning?
Christina would do.
She would break into someone's home and then kill them over.
They're outdated food.
Yeah.
I'd be so mad just shoving bad hot dogs up there and milk's expired.
Get the fuck Outta here please.
Documents reveal.
She texted him 65,000 times.
She to do hard time for this.
Many of those messages.
Did you hear her?
She goes,
I thousand times.
That's it.
Let me see.
Like more many of those messages show disturbing delusions of murder and hey,
I want to talk about that,
but she admits he blocked her number.
I told him if he ever blocked me on what's APP that I would kind of move here.
Oh,
do blocked me.
Oh Man.
Yeah.
I mean,
you think he waited for 65,000 messages before he blocked her,
but she's clearly mentally ill.
Yeah.
I would've blocked her at like 2030 I'm like,
oh,
this chick's crazy.
I could see her killing somebody and yeah,
I'm really good at talking people off the ledge.
Or You,
I know when people are crazy,
you kind of talk them off.
How do you tell?
How do you do it?
Just you.
You know?
You just can't find if there's a soul in that dead wood,
right?
Yeah.
And you just gotta try it.
I think people at the end of the day just want to be treated like a human being
and you just kind of slowly got to take them.
You know?
She's probably hooked on his Dick Smack to you think so.
You ever meet like,
like this sex call,
like these dudes get these girls,
the brand themselves.
I can't even get chicks.
Give me hand jobs and this guy's getting a fucking gardening Keith.
He runs a fucking cult named Keith.
Yeah.
Branding.
Getting random chicks are branding themselves.
Jesus Christ investigator.
See Jacqueline showed up last crazy eyes that says I love anal.
Those high stripe as white.
She says she got a text message through a fake number.
A number she thought was from her dream,
man.
I was like,
please don't tell me that this is you sending me fake text messages because you
want me to come over and say you're calling the police on me again.
She may be afraid of,
you know,
ever warn you that he was going to call the police.
He didn't stop texting.
No.
Now in court documents,
there is a box that's checked indicating that she's mentally disturbed and bars
with no bond.
Girls going heavy on the makeup haunts like the Rodeo clown makeup.
She's rocking right there.
Why are they treating this like a normal story?
Like I know her.
She's mentally so clear.
That's kind of her fault that's bothering me.
That they're like,
she's just a lady that over did it.
She's not.
She's clearly offer Rockerman.
Yeah,
stop treating it like it's a normal no.
Oh my God.
No,
I love him so much.
Yeah,
she's got like,
see,
that's the problem with this country is like,
he doesn't like it.
Then I'll go home and I love my explanations.
What am I supposed to do?
And she's great point of love is to keep giving it best fit math equation.
It's love equals 3.3,
which is infinity.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's clear she's got mental problems.
She can't think clearly and great guests on the podcast.
I would love that.
We'll break it down.
I just wanna know like these girls would go on these,
these millionaire websites.
It's just like you're asking for trouble.
No.
Right.
I mean like you're looking for something that doesn't necessarily,
not that I'm saying bang broke Dick's by any,
I mean,
I would totally not,
but it's just like you're looking for a certain type of person right there.
I just think it leads to trouble.
Yeah.
That's fine.
It's not like they're real love.
It's not a good idea to be on either side of the millionaire site,
millionaire,
a sugar baby thing.
So weird.
Um,
real quick,
uh,
someone says,
I just want to throw out a thank you.
You might not think of your podcast.
It's something that can help people in their everyday lives.
I'm a 40 year old white,
cisgender male kind of detective for police department.
What we receive,
little to no training about the LGTBQ plus community.
Just recently I was assigned to investigate a robbery assault case.
I met with the victim multiple face piercings,
cuts on the arms,
should let me know right away.
She in parentheses and quotation marks was non-binary.
If it wasn't for the podcast,
I would have been like,
what the fuck is that?
Then I thought about your podcast and wanted to laugh.
Then the scene from lethal weapon popped in my head with Murdoch saying,
I'm too old for this shit,
but I'm a professional.
I quickly replied,
what's Your Pronoun?
Oh Wow.
This person had a look on their face and said that she is fine.
Oh,
so she's not buying it,
but that that she referred to herself as she.
She tried to tell me what happened,
but would lose track and go off something.
Mel,
she showed me all the text messages,
Facebook posts between her and the suspects.
I had to decipher who did what to who.
Since everyone was describing her as a he and the multiple suspects with
different pronouns that were involved.
I ended up giving her my card,
asked her that.
She emailed me with a detailed statement.
Just wanted you guys know.
Wait a minute.
Hold on my Pronoun High and tight,
Kevin.
Well,
how about that?
Thanks Kev.
N N?
No,
I call him.
Kevin doesn't want to be called that as his son.
His keeping the streets safe.
They didn't give their pronouns.
No,
but that's,
how about that?
This podcast helped to detective in the Trans Community.
See,
he really would it well,
as soon as that person,
I'm sorry,
the not trans.
It's a bite nine binary.
It's different.
Am I a gender identity?
I try to be sent,
so I'm just saying my syllables.
Sammy of mount up.
Where'd you get that hat?
Which,
oh,
it's a are most man.
I have a buddy of mine.
Oh really?
Armenians dude.
Yeah,
this rack thing.
Boom.
Oh,
that's cool.
Makes us some really great shirts.
And I wears hats whenever I can.
This is my buddy's podcasts.
Uh,
he's kind of the top dog in the conspiracy world podcast,
higher side chats.
He goes deep.
Um,
one of the things we do on this show,
we want to have you on the podcast.
We'll do it.
I like to have you both and we won't go into the weird shit that will make you
uncomfortable.
I'm not uncomfortable.
I just don't know anything.
Well that's what's kind of fun to bring you on and talk about it.
Dope when it hears.
The,
another thing we do is we always come up with,
um,
alternative names for cities when we do our dates.
Yeah.
And we always try to make them juvenile and silly.
So for instance,
Jacksonville,
when I plug it,
I'll say Jack me off hill.
Yeah.
Orlando's horror.
Lando,
Pittsburgh,
Pittsburgh and so on.
Yeah.
We were that we realized we didn't have one for Los Angeles.
So people devastated.
Submitted.
Uh,
because we were saying we don't have them.
There's a lost angel tits.
Yup.
Good.
I love that.
Cox Angeles.
Good floss.
Angeles for the dental floss.
Yeah,
for sure.
Fuck Angeles.
Yeah.
Mom's angels.
Yup.
Los Angeles.
I like that one.
Hot Candle.
Tits.
Lost Anal fists please.
Last anal fists.
I love candle tits.
I like candles too.
So there you go.
There's some foot San Francisco man.
Randos goes man for Cisco.
Manfred disco man,
friend disco.
Yeah,
I love that.
Yeah.
And what is Sacramento?
Sacramento.
Paul Sacramento.
Very underrated city.
Yeah.
At first stand up.
It's phenomenal.
Phenomenal.
Tampa is to tap on Tampon is for sure.
New York City is,
well,
Jude Dork.
Titties.
Sure.
Jude Dork.
Titties.
Yeah.
I'm so in.
I love to be the best.
Yeah.
You liked you too?
Oh yeah.
They're number two on my super freak big board.
Who's number one?
Mexicans.
Yeah,
just
all there.
The Er,
they can just walk that fine line between being able to meet your mom and angel
on the first day.
You know what I'm saying?
Like it's fun.
Oh,
Mexican girls,
Mexican girls.
Oh yeah.
Before it gets too late here,
we encouraging um,
our listeners to hit up Cardi B,
Christina and Cardi B are doing the same day.
Oh,
that makes,
so we're just trying to get people into that.
That'd be great.
Um,
so they're,
they're sending these tweets out to Cardi B I saw,
you know,
a hundred last words of them.
They're saying Cardi B are having babies at the same time and they keep tagging
her.
She is,
I am Cardi B,
we just went Cardi B to see it and say something.
So I think she should,
you're bullied very famous mothers,
you know that you're due to have your baby while the famous Christina P is
having hers.
Is this a publicity stunt?
What if she knew that?
I just want acknowledgement from her because it's like you knew I was getting
pregnant in October.
You planned it to,
and you know what I mean.
Yeah.
We're friends.
We're bros.
It's kind of like a,
you know,
uh,
Avengers,
infinity wars.
And then they had like the legion,
the Legion of superheroes to DC version,
which was a very bad version.
So you have yours,
which is the affinity of wars and she's having hers,
which is the all hall of justice or the Legion of Justice Batman.
It was just not good.
She combined forces work together.
I got is killing me.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But you power through a Sam Tripoli.
He's got the tin foil,
tin foil,
higher comedy,
not comedy,
a tinfoil hat with Sam Tripoli.
And then punch drunk.
What?
Ours feared Jason Tebow.
And you can see him live doing the show in both sides.
A man friend describes and a,
yeah,
we're this Friday night at the,
um,
at the comedy store and the,
we're doing a live podcast.
We're kind of doing a run through,
and then we're June 1st at cops and June 2nd at Sacramento.
Punchline.
Holla at your boy.
I can't wait.
I can't worry.
Mont Street by Pos.
Enjoy it.
Thanks guys.
Itch.
Okay.
Yes.
And address
itch.
Wait.
Oh,
the
shit out.
Call me.
Put me in your class.
Pretty much
itchy.